♪ ♪
>> Greg: OUR FAVORITE
BILLIONAIRE WEIRDO IS TIME'S
PERSON OF THE YEAR-DO.
ELON MUSK -- NEVER HEARD OF
HIM -- HAS BEEN NAMED DUE TO THE
YEAR BY THE MAGAZINE YOU FORGOT
WAS THERE WHICH COMPANY INTO
SPEND AN EXTRA HUNDRED DOLLARS
SO WE COULD OWN TIME AS WELL IN
ADDITION TO BEING THE WORLD
WHICH IS MEN, SEALTEST L'ENFANT
OF SPACEX, IS ALSO MAJOR
ADVOCATE FOR COLONIZING MARS.
THAT'S A PLANET, KAT.
AND GETTING HAIRCUTS AFTER 50.
I BELIEVE THAT PARTICULAR STYLE
IS CALLED "I'M SUPER RICH SO
YOU'RE GOING TO SLEEP WITH ME
ANYWAY WAS QUOTE.
THAT'S WHY HE WAS CHOSEN THIS
YEAR, THEY WRITE IN THE PROFILE.
"HE HAS SPENT A LIFETIME DEFYING
THE HATERS."
NOW IT SEEMS HE'S FINALLY A
POSITION PUT THEM IN THEIR PLACE
FOR 2021 WITH THE YEAR OF ELON
UNBOUND.
WHAT?
BECAUSE BEFORE THIS YEAR HE WAS
JUST A GENIUS MULTIBILLIONAIRE
THAT DATED BEAUTIFUL ACTRESSES.
LOOKS LIKE THE MAGAZINE IS LATE
AGAIN.
PRETTY BAD FOR A MAGAZINE NAMED
TIME PERIOD OF TIME ALSO SAYS
HE'S ONE OF THE FEW PEOPLE
WORTHY OF BEING DESCRIBED AS
LARGER-THAN-LIFE.
I SUPPOSE THEY HAVEN'T MET
YOU-KNOW-WHO.
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
I AM!
I AM.
HIS MUSK REALLY THOUGH RIGHT
CHOICE FOR THE PERSON OF THE
YEAR?
BRIAN KILMEADE'S THERAPIST GOES
UNRECOGNIZED?
WHAT ABOUT THE YAHOO! GROUPS KAT
'S HAIR EXTENSIONS?
TALK ABOUT AN UNSUNG HERO.
THAT'S A GOOD QUICK ROUND OUT OF
THIS.
WHO SHOULD BE PERSON OF THE
YEAR?
SHOULDN'T IT RHYME WITH SMEG
SMUTFELD?
>> I THINK IT SHOULD BE THE
PERSON WHO STILL READS TIME.
THE SINGER PERSON.
IT'S A PAMPHLET.
>> Greg: LARRY, WHO SHOULD BE
THE PERSON OF THE YEAR?
I ACTUALLY DO THINK THIS IS A
GOOD CHOICE.
I LOVE ELON MUSK.
>> I THINK ELON MUSK IS
TERRIFIC, HE'S REALLY SMART AND
HERE'S ANOTHER THING I REALLY
LOVE ABOUT HIM.
I'M SURPRISED THE LEFTIES WOULD
GIVE HIM THIS AWARD.
HE IS THE BIGGEST ELECTRIC CAR
MAKER RIGHT?
NUMBER ONE.
SO HE HAS COME OUT TOTALLY
OPPOSED TO ALL OF BIDENS
GREEN NEW DEAL SUBSIDIES FOR
ELECTRIC CARS AND BATTERIES.
HE'S AGAINST IT.
AND THAT'S VERY COOL.
IN EFFECT HE JUST CAME OUT
AGAINST BIDENS ENTIRE BILL,
WHICH THE REST OF THE COUNTRY
ALSO HATES.
SO FOR A CEO AND A SMART GUY AND
TIME PUT HIM ON THE COVER, HE'S
A CONSERVATIVE, HE'S A
LIBERTARIAN, HE'S VERY COOL.
I'M FOR HIM, I LIKE THE GUY.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW, TYRUS, IS
HE A SAVIOR OR SUPER VILLAIN?
>> HE'S NEITHER.
HE'S A -- HE IS THERE HOPE, HE'S
THE MODERATE DEMOCRATS' HOPE.
BECAUSE THE PROGRESSIVES HATE
HIM.
FIRST OF ALL, HE DOESN'T FILL IN
ENOUGH BOXES TO BE PERSON OF
THEIR ACCOMPLISHMENTS BY JUST
PURE BEING GOOD WITH MONEY.
THAT'S RACIST BURIED HIM SO HE'S
OUT OF THERE, YOU KNOW?
AND I HATE TO BE THE ONE TO
BRING THIS UP, BUT APPARENTLY
HE'S A WHITE MALE.
>> Greg: AND STRAIGHT.
>> APPARENTLY HE'S A BREEDER.
YOU CAN A COUPLE OF BREEDERS IN
YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD, ALL HELL
BREAKS LOOSE.
THE LITTLE THINGS RUNNING ON --
>> Greg: WHAT ARE THOSE THINGS
ANYWAY?
>> I DON'T KNOW, THEY'RE BAD.
SO HE IS DISQUALIFIED BY EVERY
LEFTIST MAGAZINE ON THE PLANET
AND TIME IS GOING -- HE CAN
STAND UP TO HIM, HE STAND UP TO
BIDEN, HE IS STILL HERE, YOU
CAN'T CANCEL HIM BECAUSE HE WILL
JUST WRITE YOU A CHECK.
>> Greg: I WISH YOU WOULD
WRITE ME A CHECK.
I SHOULD BE MEN OF YOUR FOR
RESCUING LATE NIGHT FROM A
HUMORLESS LEFT.
[SCATTERED CHEERS]
>> Greg: THEY AGREE.
THEY AGREE.
>> HOW DID THAT FEEL?
>> Greg: 10,000 PEOPLE IN THE
AUDIENCE, GOOD.
>> YOU WANT ME TO AGREE WITH
YOU?
YEAH, YES.
ALTHOUGH, I DON'T GET THIS.
IF INFLUENTIAL -- I'M NOT
INFLUENCED BY HIM.
>> Greg: NO?
>> NO.
>> Greg: WHO WOULD YOU WANT?
>> YOUR LINE, EVERYONE IS LYING
IF YOU SAY ANYONE OTHER THAN
YOUR OWN SELF HIS OR HER OWN
SELF'S PERSON INFLUENTIAL OF THE
YEAR.
>> SO PUT A MIRROR.
>> YEAH, ME.
FOR ME ONLY.
>> Greg: DIDN'T THEY DO THAT
ONCE?
>> AND EVERYONE PUTS IN THEIR
TWITTER BIO, THIS YEAR -- BLAH,
BLAH, BLAH, MOST OFFICIAL
PERSON, BUT THEY'RE REALLY NOT.
IT'S NOT THAT FUNNY.
>> IT'S NOT.
>> Greg: IT'S NOT.
I THINK OUR SHOW PROVES THAT
AGAIN AND AGAIN.
FOR EXAMPLE, IN THIS SEGME